MIHAI IONESCU: Hey, guys.
Welcome to another session
of Payments on
Google Developers Live.
Today we're going do a
Hangout-style session on the
East Coast.
I have my colleague Peng.
Hi, Peng.
PENG YING: What's
up, everybody?
MIHAI IONESCU: All right.
So a quick check there that you
guys can see both of us.
And over the past few sessions,
we got a lot of
questions I didn't have
time to answer.
We also looked on the forums
on Stack Overflow.
We looked on the Moderator that
we just posted a few days
ago, gathered some questions.
And we tried to answer those
as good as we can.
Of course, looking for
suggestions and feedback of
what you want to hear
on future sessions.
So before we get started, I
have a quick announcement.
We recently announced a series
of DevFest developer events
based on Google products.
And there is a very interesting
one coming up.
I'm going to share my screen
here to show you the website.
So it's called DevFest
West, and it will--
you guys can see?
OK, you can see the site.
It will happen October 20 to 21
at Google headquarters in
Mountain View, California.
So if you're in the
San Francisco Bay
Area, please attend.
It's going to be
fun, two days.
There are going to be parties
there are going to be code
labs, a very interesting
session.
Of course, we're going to
talk about payments.
So if you have time, make
sure you don't miss it.
It's on a weekend, so mark
it on your calendars.
Now, with that out of the way,
let's go over some questions.
So let me look at--
PENG YING: I have a
question first.
I'm on our page, and then
I'm trying to see if
the video is live.
Can everybody see our live
stream right now?
MIHAI IONESCU: I think so.
PENG YING: OK.
Just making sure.
Because it looks like on our
Google Developers Live page,
the live stream isn't the
right live stream.
MIHAI IONESCU: It probably has
a small delay there, but I
think we're fine.
PENG YING: OK.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, I
think if you refresh,
then you'll see it.
And that's actually
a very good point.
Probably.
if some people joined earlier,
they would need to
refresh now to see us.
Good.
Let's start with a question.
So we launched subscription
about a month ago, and a lot
of people have been trying it,
quite a few launches, and, of
course, there are lots
of questions.
It's a new product.
And we still have
some work to do.
So I'll start with
a question here.
"If a recurring subscription
transaction failed, for
example, because the credit
card expired, would the
substitution be canceled
immediately?
Or will the customer to be able
to update the payment
method?" So that's a
very common case.
You have a long-term
subscription.
You bill your customer
monthly.
And let's say he or she signed
up for a couple of years.
But as is the case, a lot of
credit cards expire monthly--
sorry, yearly, or
every two years.
So if that happens and the
credit card has expired
mid-subscription period, then,
of course, the subscription,
the recurring subscription
transaction, will fail.
So when that happens, the
customer will receive a
notification, an email.
And we will give instructions
on how to
update the credit card.
There will be a link and
step-by-step instructions to
update the credit card link
for that specific
subscription.
The customer will have three
days to update the credit card
and retry the substitution.
If there are other specific
cases besides the credit card
expiration, he or she will also
have the option to go and
immediately retry the
subscription or contact their
credit card company to see
what's going wrong.
So from your point of view as a
merchant, you don't have to
worry about that.
If a subscription fails, then
the customer will be notified,
and they will have the
option to update
their credit card online.
If you see other cases where
that is not happening, please
let us on the forum on Stack
Overflow or on our biweekly
Office Hours.
One more question.
Peng, do you want to
take that one?
PENG YING: Yep.
So the question I have "is it
possible to create a Google
Wallet account without actually
being in the USA or
adding my credit
or debit cards?
I'm writing a web application in
which I want to support the
Add-to-Google Wallet option.
Is it possible?"
So I think I need a little bit
more context here, because we
have multiple purchase
methods.
We have multiple options.
And then I'm not quite sure if
they're looking to sign up as
a buyer or sign up
as a merchant.
So I'm going to try to cover
pretty much everything.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, let's talk
about both cases and give
a quick overview of the sign-up
process in both
situations.
PENG YING: Yep.
So as a buyer, Google Wallet
supports over 140 countries
and almost all of the
payment flows.
So in payment flows like
Androids or Google Play,
Checkouts, Google Wallet for
Digital Goods, all of these
different payment flows support
buyers from over 140
different countries.
Now, in order to be able
to complete the
purchase, we only support--
well, it depends on
the purchase flow.
So, for example, if you're
purchasing on Android, you
will have credit cards, debit
cards, and carrier billing.
In Checkouts, we only support
credit cards and debit cards,
and the same is for Google
Wallet for digital goods.
On the merchant side, it's
a little bit different.
So for merchants, you can sign
up for merchant accounts for
Checkout in two countries--
US and UK.
You can sign up for merchant
accounts for Google Wallet for
Digital Goods in 18 countries.
And there's an FAQ
with the list of
countries that we support.
And then for Android, you can
sign up for a merchant account
in 31 different countries.
And we're always looking to
continually expand the number
of countries that each of these
payment methods support.
But you know, it takes a little
bit more time for each
of these as well.
In terms of signing up without
a credit or debit card, you
can supply your federal tax
ID in most of these cases.
So you don't need to enter in
your credit card or debit
cards as part of your
identification.
So I hope that answers
your question.
And if it doesn't, then please
follow up on the forums, and
then we'll have--
I mean, we always check
the forums.
So somebody will be there and
see if we can provide a better
answer to your question.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
Thanks, Peng.
So we're always looking to
improve the sign-up process.
It is cumbersome, but we have
to follow all kinds of
financial regulations.
And based on your feedback and
usability studies, we're
trying to make that process
as simple as possible.
So the next question, I'll
take the next one.
It's also related to payments,
and probably this is a new
merchant trying the
subscriptions API.
And the question is "the Digital
Goods API sometimes
uses a pop-up window to ask
the user for information.
Is it possible to disable
the pop-up?"
So sometimes that can
create problems,
especially on mobile devices.
And the reason we are requiring
a pop-up is to
securely log in the user or
transmit information, private
information, such as credit
card payments.
So there is a very good
reason for the pop-up.
On the other hand, we agree
that it is not a very nice
user interface issue.
So we're looking at ways to
remove that and make it
simpler and seamless for users
of the Digital Goods API to
either sign in or complete
a transaction.
Note that that happens only the
first time the user logs
in or the first time they
enter the credit card
information.
If they already have a Google
Checkout account and they
already have payment
methods set up, you
will not see the pop-up.
Or you will see it very rarely
if the user did not login to
the account for weeks.
So stay tuned.
We're looking for ways to
improve that and make it a
better user experience.
PENG YING: All right.
I'll take the next question.
And it is "what is the current
criteria for getting started
as a merchant?
Or do you have any time frame
for general availability?" And
I think this one needs
a little bit
more context as well.
So I guess I'll talk
about the different
purchase flows for merchants.
There's Checkouts.
There's Google Wallet
for Digital Goods.
There is, I guess,
Google Play.
And then there is Google Wallet
for Online Commerce.
I'm guessing that this one is
specifically geared towards
Google Wallet for Online
Commerce, because the other
ones are open sign-up
right now.
But let's walk through
each of them anyway.
So for Checkouts, you
just need to be a--
it's open sign-up.
You need to be a US or UK
merchant, because those are
the only two countries that
we support for Checkout.
And then you need to sign up
with either a credit card or
your federal tax ID.
For Google Play, I believe that
you need to sign up to be
a developer of Google Play.
And I think the requirements are
the same, but we support
additional countries.
For Google Wallet for
Digital Goods,
we support 18 countries.
And I think it's the
same information
for sign-up as well.
And then for the last one,
Google Wallet for Online
Commerce, right now we're
accepting applicants.
I don't know if we have
specific criteria.
I think we're just
looking for--
because we've kind of soft
launched, we haven't fully
launched yet, that we're
just looking for great
partners work with.
MIHAI IONESCU: Do we have
a website or a way for
interested merchants
to sign up?
PENG YING: Yeah, there should
be a sign-up on the Google
Wallet for Online Commerce
developers page.
I think there's a link
in the Nav somewhere.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK, so just
express your interest, and
then we'll follow up with
additional information on how
to sign up.
PENG YING: Yep.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yep, right?
Looks like there's interest on
an API that's just launched.
That's always good news.
All right, I'll take
the next one.
I'm getting the easy
questions, Peng.
You've got the more
complicated ones.
PENG YING: I feel like I'm
doing a lot of talking.
MIHAI IONESCU: It's also about
subscriptions, and someone
who's trying different
variations on subscriptions.
The question is "when
a customer cancels a
subscription, a digital
subscription before the
expiration date, will prorated
refunds be issued?"
So the policy that we have right
now is when a customer
cancels a subscription
mid-period before the end of
the next subscription period,
then there will be no refunds.
The entire subscription will run
out until the end of the
next period, after which
it will be canceled.
However, as a merchant, you can
show goodwill or decide to
offer the customer
other options.
In this case, you can decide
to do a prorated refund.
You can do that from the
merchant center, where you go
and refund a specific amount.
You can refund for the
entire period.
It's all entirely up to you.
So you have a choice in this
case, or you can let the
subscription run out.
As a quick point for
non-technical related
questions regarding
subscriptions, I would
recommend to go look
at the Help Center.
It's a little hard to find, but
if I can share the screen
here, I can show you where it is
on our documentation page.
So let me go back to
the page here.
And if we go on our Digital
Goods API page, if you look on
the side navigation bar on the
Resources Help Center, if you
click on Help Center, it will
take you to a merchant
end-user help center.
And most likely, you will
find the answers to
such questions there.
Cool Want to take the
next question?
PENG YING: Yep.
I think we've covered this one
before, but we're just going
to go over it again.
"Why is Google Wallet not
available on Verizon Galaxy
Nexus?"
MIHAI IONESCU: Oh, yeah.
We answer that every session.
PENG YING: Yeah.
It's a Nexus device.
So I mean, I can't really get
into the details about why.
But I just wanted everybody to
know that we are in talks with
the carriers.
And I mean, it's the powers that
we're working with, the
powers that be, right?
You know, we want to make Wallet
available everywhere.
So we're still trying to push
for it, and then we'll see
where it goes.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's the answer
we've been giving you
guys for the past few months.
But we always have new
announcements.
And things happen
really quickly.
PENG YING: Yeah.
One of these days, we're
going to be like, boom.
Yeah.
MIHAI IONESCU: We don't
know what else to say.
Pretty soon.
All right.
Another hard question for you,
another easy one for me.
So let me go--
OK.
So I'm getting all the digital
payments and subscription
questions today.
And this one is about the--
"are there plans--" it's
about programmatic API?
So the question is "are there
plans to allow merchants to
cancel and refund
subscriptions
programmatically?" So that is
a very good question, and
obviously, it's a
very useful API.
If you're a high-volume
merchant, you have a high
download subscriptions, you do
not have time to do refunds or
cancellations manually.
So that's where a programmatic
API will come in very handy
and allow you to automate
the entire process.
And the good news is that we
have that in the works, and it
will be available very soon
for beta testing.
We're asking you guys for
additional feedback and what
other APIs you think will be
useful, so stay tuned.
We'll announce something
very soon.
PENG YING: Cool.
I'll get the next question.
"I'm testing Checkout
in the sandbox.
The merchant's account currency
is in US dollars, but
I want to place an
order in euros.
How can I change the account
currency to euros?"
Well, for Checkout,
it's an older API.
Right now, it's still restricted
to US and UK
merchants only.
You can only bill in the
currency of your account.
So if your account is a US
account, you can only bill in
US dollars.
If your account is a UK account,
you can bill in
British pounds.
So that's kind of restrictive.
However, we have a separate API
called Google Wallet for
Digital Goods.
The main purpose of it, as the
API name states, is to sell or
enable the purchase
of digital goods.
And with this API, what you're
actually able to do is you can
specify any of something like 20
currencies or 29 currencies
and then have us automatically
convert the charge amounts--
the native currency
charge amount--
to the currency of
your account.
So it really depends on what
you're looking for.
If you're looking to sell
physical goods, unfortunately,
you won't be able to do this
right now with Checkout.
But if you're selling digital
goods, we have a solution for
you called Google Wallet
for Digital Goods.
MIHAI IONESCU: And in this
particular situation, where
the user is looking to sell in
the euros, we are supporting
most of the countries
in the eurozone.
So out of the 18 countries
supported for Google for
Digital Goods, a lot of them
are using the euros.
So you can have euro count in
euros and go ahead and sell.
PENG YING: Yep.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
My turn.
All right.
I have another easy one.
So someone has been asking--
has been posting this question
on the Google+ stream.
And the question is "how can I
join the Wallet team?" And
that is a fantastic question.
And we are hiring on
multiple levels.
It's not clear if this developer
wants to join the
Developer Relations team, or the
Wallet engineering team.
But we're hiring in both of
them, and I can share my
screen again and show you
where you can go look.
So the easiest place to
start is if you go to
developers.google.com/jobs,
where all the Developer
Relations jobs are listed,
starting with developer
advocates, developer programs
engineer, program manager,
technical writers.
Browse through those
and follow the
links for more details.
The interview process is similar
for most positions.
And after you will receive an
offer, then you can decide
which area you're more
interested in.
PENG YING: Come join our team.
Come join our team.
It's great.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes.
Come join our team, exactly.
The Wallet team is hiring.
So, yeah, Go check out either
developers.google.com/jobs, or
google.com/jobs.
Lots of very good information
on both sides.
PENG YING: Yep.
All right, and then I have
another question.
"When will the Google Wallet
for Online Commerce APIs be
available internationally?" Now,
that's a tough question,
because right now, we've only
kind of soft launched.
So even in the US, we're trying
to launch in the US
first, grow the merchant user
base here, and then launch
internationally, of course,
after that.
Right now, what we're
doing is we--
like with our other pay methods,
we're only supporting
credit cards and debit cards.
And as a lot of you know, most
countries in the world, or
only like a few countries in the
world, actually use credit
cards and debit cards
very heavily.
It would be the US, the UK,
maybe France, probably
Australia and Canada, right?
So I mean, we definitely want
to expand internationally.
But I can't really get into a
time scope or time frame.
MIHAI IONESCU: Things are
moving fast, guys.
So don't lose patience.
It'll happen.
All right.
We are at the end
of our session.
It looks like we don't have
any more questions.
Just a quick reminder that we
want you guys to attend our
DevFest West.
I'm going to put again
the website on.
So this, register
if you have not.
There will be code labs,
parties, and, of course, all
kinds of interesting sessions,
including a
session on Wallet APIs.
So are we done?
PENG YING: Yeah.
MIHAI IONESCU: Thank
you for attending.
We're looking forward to seeing
you guys again in a
couple of weeks.
And let us know how
we're doing.
Let us know what topics you want
to hear on the forum or
on the Google+ stream.
PENG YING: And remember
to apply.
Yeah, remember to apply
to join our team.
MIHAI IONESCU: Oh, yes.
And whoever is interested in
jobs with the Wallet team,
please apply.
All right, thanks, Peng.
Thanks, everyone,
for attending.
PENG YING: Always a pleasure.
MIHAI IONESCU: We'll see
you back in two weeks.
Bye-bye.
PENG YING: See you, guys.